this series as we did the previous
series what happened I mean I thought a
lot of it looks we're similar looks just
had to make shots you know I think
sometimes as a shooter to the shots just
don't fall and then you start trying to
make shots a little bit too hard you
know you start trying too hard to make
shots maybe take a few toughen and then
that just makes it you know a longer
night sometimes and I think over the
course of the series or at least after
game one just haven't seen the ball go
in consistent enough and my job is to
stay aggressive you know keep doing what
I do and tonight you know shots fill
Jamestown High complete report you've
never been in a game seven in your
career in the playoffs what what are you
expecting or do you have any kind of
thoughts on you know what you know what
happens for your inner spectre what how
you're gonna prepare for it I mean I
think it's you know as always people
saying you know people have never been
in a game seven but this is basically a
game where only one team is gonna make
it up you know as you're your last
opportunity to play so facing
elimination is what it is to me you know
it's gonna be my approaching we was
facing elimination tonight one thing
there's no changes it's gonna be on the
road and this as far as season for all
the marbles so for me I'm not going in
there saying oh I've never been in the
game seven I'm going in there saying I
know what this team is capable of I know
what I am and who I am as a player and
you know I'm going there to get the job
done I'm not concerned would it be in
Game seven or or whatever you know it's
not Game seven of the finals so is what
it is
Casey oh no trouble um what did you
think a bit drips game tonight and way
and how much different is it for you
guys when he's able to play like that I
thought it was great you know for him to
be coming over and helping on a lot of
the penetration on the you know some of
the mismatches on the block that they
were looking to exploit with Millsap and
you know contesting shots blocking shots
boxing those guys out limited in a
second and third opportunities for him
just play with confidence you know got
to the free-throw line and made free
throws she took open shots
went up strong to the rim and there was
a dunk or he was getting contact but I
just think his aggressiveness how sharp
he was mentally in the rotations and you
know a lot of adjustments that we wanted
to make I think that was the the most
impressive things that he did you know a
lot of people on the outside they just
look for made shots missed shots you
know the obvious stats but it's a lot of
stuff you know that you walk through and
shoot arounds and that you go through
when you watch film you know changes
that way in just positioning and stuff
that you want other players and I
thought he was really good in in that
way you know so a lot of people might
not notice those things but as his
teammates we notice how sharp he was and
those things that we wanted to do Dame
Mike Richmond NBC Sports what does it
mean to have Newark on the bench with
you guys and has he told you how hard it
is for him to watch these games I mean
it he's a part of the team so having him
there it feels more complete
you know you sometimes you look down
there and when he's not there you like
madness you can tell somebody's missing
you know a player is missing and he's
also a talkative person so you know you
feel his presence and today was actually
the first time that he said to me when I
was sitting next to him on the bench he
said man I wish I could play with my
broken leg I will go out there right now
and get hurt again if I could and I was
like man this dude is crazy but it was
right after they showed him on the
screen and the crowd went crazy and you
know he must have got one of those
feelings again and that's how he was
feeling at the moment I guess